نبدا اولا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه حيث
افادت سلطات الاوكرانيه بتعرض العاصمه
كياف ومقاطعات اخرى مساء اليوم لموجه
جديده من القصف الروسي وفي حصيله اوليه
افادت سلطات الاوكرانيه عن مقتل شخص في
كاف واصابه احد عشر اخرين في القصف الروسي
بينهم صحفي ياباني نستعرض الوضع المكياف
مع مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي وتفاصيل
هذا القصف تامر
نعم تواجد الان في قلب العاصمه في احدى
المناطق التي تعرضت للقصف في الخلفيه احد
الفنادق الرئيسيه في العاصمه كيف التي
تعرضت همم قصف بصاروخ الروسيه وفقا
للسلطات الاوكرانيا نحاول ان نقرب لكم
صوره في الحقيقه الدمار كبير هنا في همم
اجزاء كبيره من هذا الفندق الذي تعرض
للقصف وفي الحقيقه هذا الموقع واحد من
ثلاثه مواقع تعرضت اليوم في العاصمه كيف
في ضواحي كيا في منطقه كياف ل- اا قصف
صواريخ روسيه السلطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
هنا تقول بان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
تعمل كل ما بوسعها لاسقاط الصواريخ التي
تستهدف العاصمه عمده كيف تحدث خلال
الدقائق الاخيره بان همم
اصفر عن مقتل مدني واصابه 13 اخرين بينهم
صحفي ياباني كان يقيم في العاصمه كياف
ويعمل على تغطيه الاحداث وقال بان احدى
الاصابات حالتها حرجه في الحقيقه وفقا
للاداره العسكريه هنا في العاصمه المناطق
التي تم استهدافها هي مناطق مدنيه تحديدا
في منطقه كيف كما تشاهدون الشضايا ال- ال-
الصاروخ همم يمكن مشاهدتها على هذا على
الطريق يعني يمكن للزميلها المصور ان يقرب
لكم هذا الدمار المتواجد الان في محيط
الفندق على الارض وهنالك ايضا الواجهات
المقابله لعمرات اخرى لهذا الفندق تعرضت
ايضا لشضايا الصاروخ كما تشاهدون النوافذ
كسرت الى حد كبير خشمت الى حد كبير وفي
الحقيقه هذا القصف الذي تتحدث عنه السلطات
ما زال متواصلا الهجوم الروسي ما زال
متواصلا وفقا لالسلطات الاوكرانيه همم
قليل يجري الحديث من قبل همم عمده كيف
ايضا خلال هذه الدقيقه بان الدفاعات
الجويه تعمل مره اخرى في قلب العاصمه
الدفاعات الجويه تعمل مره اخرى في قلب
العاصمه همم كياف وتقول السلطات بانها
تعمل على ذلك بشكل متواصل والهجوم استهدف
ايضا مقاطعات كثيره في جنوب البلاد
زيباروجيا خيرسون
وتزامن كل ذلك مع رساله وجهها وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني خلال ساعات الماضيه باللغه
الروسيه للمواطنين الروس قال لهم بان
عليهم المغادره همم لان السلطات
الاوكرانيه ستعمل على تعبئه جديده للجيش
الاوكراني في بدايه هذا العام وقال بان
روسيا هزمت بشكل كامل في اوكرانيا ولكنها
تغطي على كل ذلك نتابعه ابرز ما قال
السيسي
وخصوصا سكان المدن الكبرى المؤهلين الى
الخدمه العسكريه مازال لديكم الوقت سلطات
بلادكم ستغلق الحدود وهتعلن تعبئه جديده
في يناير المقبل منذ 10 اشهر اعلن سلطاتكم
عن عمليه عسكريه سريعه وغير مكلفه لكن
السفينه الرائده للاصول الروسي دمرت وكذلك
دمرته طائرات وعلى اراضي المطارات الروسيه
فسير القوات الروسيه تتخطى 100 الف قتيل
لذلك تحتاج موسكو للتعبئه من جديد ومنذ
سته اشهر يهاجم الجيش الروسي مدينه
الصغيره
لقد خسرت روسيا الحرب لكنها لا تستطيع لا
اعتراف بذلك
شكرا لك يا تامر الصمادي مراسل جزيره من
كيفك